what's up guys bang bang i'm sitting
here just thinking about it it's pretty
crazy ray dalio steve cohen stanley
druckenmiller now george soros a bunch
of the most well respected folks howard
marks all of them they're all in the
game if you're a multi-billionaire on
wall street and you got cash you're
buying bitcoin why we can't print
trillions of dollars and expect the
dollar to remain stable there's going to
be higher levels of inflation of course
over five percent cpi over four percent
core inflation that's why you're seeing
all these multi-billionaire very well
respected hedge fund managers and asset
allocators buying bitcoin they're all in
the game and so whether it was paul
tudor jones and stanley druckenmiller
last year or it's the steve cohens and
the howard marx and now the george soros
is all jumping in that's what they do
they move their assets around tactically
trying to figure out where they should
be positioned for movements in asset
prices and of course they're all
concluding what many bitcoiners have
concluded years and years ago which is
bitcoin is the apex predator in markets
and if you're going to have the
quantitative easing and the monetary and
fiscal stimulus that's occurring in the
market of course a fixed supply open
decentralized monetary network is going
to end up being incredibly valuable that
is what we're watching play out so don't
allow all of the bankers the hedge funds
and the legacy world folks to buy up all
the bitcoin because i'm not selling mine
i don't want to sell it to them we'll
see what's happening 85 of all bitcoin
in circulation right now has not moved
in the last 90 days pretty incredible to
see we'll keep watching keep paying
attention make sure that when these guys
all come in the market we can see it
right on chain we can see the whales
buying there's now competition is the
legacy world gonna hold more bitcoin or
are the bitcoin and crypto natives going
to hell end up holding more bitcoin time
will tell i like the chances of the
bitcoin and the crypto natives they
already got a big head start these guys
got a lot of cash coming from wall
street but it's unlikely that they'll be
able to catch up to all those crypto and
bitcoin natives so i'll see you out
there and by the way don't forget put up
your fingers four quarter fourth quarter
fourth quarter they had us in the first
half but we got the fourth quarter
q4 of this year is going to be insane
shocktober when you hold up for when
you're playing football fourth quarter
fourth quarter in the fourth quarter
fourth quarter
yeah they had us the first half i'm not
gonna lie fourth quarter baby they had
us the whole game but it's all about the
fourth quarter fourth quarter fourth
quarter
this is your time
their time
is done
the chairman of the federal reserve
explicitly saying no intention to ban
bitcoin obviously bitcoin is going wild
on the internet el salvador has started
to mine bitcoin using energy from
volcano the apex predator of the
financial markets is ready to roll you
play to win the game
hello you play to win the game going to
the fourth quarter of the football game
but they are who we thought they were
and we let them off the hook we can
fight our way back
into the light
we can climb out of hell we will not go
quietly into the night and remember what
got you here focus on the fundamentals
we've gone over time and time again we
can't be consumed by our petty
differences anymore
we will be united in our common
interests
we have won every single game we have
played until now
so this team
is perfect
we'll give us a little four figures in
the air for the fourth quarter
how we gonna finish it how are we gonna
close it out fourth quarter
you